j'aimerais jouer les gros bras terry wey
tu vois ce que je veux dire hexabyte
monde évidemment
jacques est charlie de traînes savates
irlandais elrik thomas eric métayer leur
donne corps à eux et à cet autre
personnage à chacun pour prépare c'est
surtout d'une grosse technicité de
rapports entre nous on se connaît
tellement que voilà et surtout un
travail qu'on connaissait aussi qu'il
travaille dur rien du vide de créer un
espace avec simplement l'imaginaire donc
ce travail là c'est simplement pas
montrer que c'est une précision très
très forte
on est très très précis dans ce qu'on
fait mais faut pas que ça se voit faut
que ça passe pour de l'improvisation
alors que ça ne l'est pas une quinzaine
de personnages pour retracer la vie des
habitants du comté de kerry des
irlandais dont le quotidien est
bouleversé par l'arrivée d'une équipe de
tournage des cailloux plein les poches
c'est le retour sur scène d'une pièce
nommée cinq fois aux molières en 2004
c'est très agréable à jouer et puis en
plus on se connaît très très bien le
plaisir à jouer ensemble un plaisir un
plaisir voilà même toujours une bonne
frite et moi ça ça que j'adore chez lui
par papa ans que ça là oui on prend
plaisir parce que on est toujours à la
recherche du frémissement de l'oeil de
l'autre que moi je passe mon temps à
essayer de chercher une connerie pour le
faire rire et que lui c'est la même
chose avec son rythme effréné cette
pièce est plus qu'une simple comédie
elle questionne aussi sur des sujets
graal c'est là son tour de force
bailly vos amis soldats anonymes an plus
tôt et des anneaux s'est produit alors
j'ai retourné schubert et à moins de
changer cela